Wonder Woman 1984 was one of the most
highly anticipated movies of 2020 and
ended up being arguably one of its worst
and certainly one of its most
disappointing the trailer did an
excellent job selling the movie
combining the girl power action that
made Patty Jenkins 2017 Wonder Woman so
refreshing with a new colorful and
nostalgic 1980s setting and style how
could you not get hyped up by that remix
of Blue Monday from New Order not having
to reveal the film's more questionable
plot elements makes everything look
better than it was when the new villain
Max Lord talks on TV about getting
everything you want you might think
you're in for a commentary on the
excesses of 80s capitalism rather than a
silly dreamstone
plotline life is good but it can be
better when the trailer shows Steve
Trevor back from the dead and reuniting
with Wonder Woman you wouldn't even
guess that the romance would involve
violating a total stranger's consent but
yes that's actually in the film